hello everyone and welcome to the
semifinals of dueling Doris a b-rabbit
challenge it's the first game of the
match Magnus Carlsen ver si Cara
Nakamura and like all the other matches
they will play not one but three matches
to decide who goes into the final so
during the rossabi rapid challenge and
it's already pretty wild from game 1 so
let's just dive straight into it but
before we do that here are their
head-to-head scores so far so you can
see in classical games Magnus Carlsen
has quite quite a positive record
against Hikaru beating him 14 to 1 with
25 draws but in a rapid and exhibition
games it's 44 to 19 with 39 Ross so
again in favor of Magnus this does not
include online games I believe these are
only over the board games but I think it
wouldn't make much of a difference if
you know in regarding ratio if we
included online games so that being said
let's check out the game Magnus opens
with E 4 we have E 5 by Hikaru Knight f3
Knight to c6 he car was always very very
comfortable going for his Berlin with
the black pieces against e4 but Magnus
now goes d4 he goes for the Scotch which
of course is very rarely seen on the
highest level but he did he did play it
somewhat after his training with wood
garry kasparov so he captures and before
we have Knight captures and Bishop to c5
now with a double attack on the night we
have Knight captures and c6 and now
before recapturing first Queen to f6 now
saying I'm gonna recapture later but
also I'm just threatening checkmate on
f2 so you have to deal with that Magnus
plays Queen f3 defense against checkmate
and now the captures on c6
we have Knight to c3 Magnus continues
developing and now Bishop to e6
we have Bishop to e3 by Magnus both
players obviously ready to Castle
queenside and now Hikaru goes for Bishop
to b4 he puts pressure on the night here
and Magnus just goes queenside castle
and it's quite the move because well
what happens if just bishop characters
and see
if captures you no longer have the
option of trading Queens because the
bishop will recapture so you would have
to capture back the problem is if you go
Queen characters and see three now now
then why it has this Bishop to d4 move
and now you have to trade Queens as the
g7 point is hanging and after characters
captures now you have to defend the pawn
let's say f6 now rubgy one goes after
the pawn and after g6 something like f4
and the white is down upon but he has
the bishop pair and well it just just a
much easier game and also if you play
this you you obviously have it over the
board at home so he called knows that
Magnus is very well prepared for this so
after after queenside castle said there
is one game where Queen to e7 was played
in the database but Hikaru just trades
Queens right away and it is as of move 9
that we have a completely new game and
he he spent quite quite a lot of time
for this movie even it's a 15-minute
game since they're playing rapid games
and he called took over five minutes for
this move so it does take a toll on his
clock so G captures on f3 and now Knight
to e7 M Magnus immediately goes for H
form he wants to play h5 and limited the
mobility of this Knight the pawn
prevents the knife from going any and if
the central squares and this pawn will
prevent it from going to g6 so here he
cowered decides to grab the knife and c3
mess up cross and spawn structure but in
doing so he gives up the bishop pair so
Bishop captures we have B captures and
now rook to d8 going for a rook trade
and Magnus obliges with rook captures
with checking characters in not h5 so
taking away the g6 Square from the
knight and preparing rook to g1 at some
point and here of course if you go after
the pawn then Magnus can just lock your
Bishop with c4 the problem is now you
were in some danger of having your
Bishop trapped so you'll have to go for
something like b5 and give back the pawn
let's say characters characters and
characters and we get this again this
position with the bishop pair against
the bishop at night but with play on
both sides of the board white should be
much better here so instead after this
h5 Mumbai Magnus also Magnus wants to
play f4 f5
pushes f5 himself he would of course
very much enjoy if Magnus captures here
but Magnus likes this pawn on e4 Hughes
so he's not gonna react to this and of
course Magnus doesn't mind captures
captures because he will just under his
pawns so c4 by Magnus grabbing more
space here and now rook to f8 Hikaru
brings the rook into the game and now
look the g1 putting pressure on the g7
pawn he called defense it with the rook
to f7 and now comes a four now Magnus
starts grabbing some space on the Queen
side as well with a six by Hikaru may be
preparing b5 at some point to grab more
space but now a five and now a Nakamura
will not be able to push b6 or B five
cents
Magnus has complete control of the b6
square of course b5 isn't met with a
captors and the six of us all
so g6 by Hikaru now challenging the pawn
here asking do you want to capture so I
can capture back but Magnus says I'm
nothing to rush to capture anything I
prefer that the position being the way
it is just rip the g5 keeping an eye on
everything now if you want you can mess
up your pawn structure I'm gonna capture
with the rook and then put pressure on
your h7 pawn so Hikaru goes look the f6
adds another defender to the g6 pawn
this way and now Magnus decides to trade
we have captures we have rook captures
and g6 offering a trade of rooks and now
even c5 by Magnus now the bishop after
the bishop moves again you have complete
control over the b6 square so you're not
allowing any counter play on the Queen
side King Teti 8 he brings the King into
the game and Bishop to d3 now with a
triple attack here on the f5 pawn and
the situation on the clock is Magnus six
minutes he covered three minutes so not
not a lot of time for Hikaru here Hikaru
trades with rook captures Bishop
captures and now h5 putting the pond to
a light Square but also just starting to
push his past age born and now King to
d2 Magnus also wants to bring the King
as deep into the position as possible so
King f8 by Hikaru
now King to e3 and now King f7 Hikaru
could have gone king of salmon right
away but what he car is doing here is
he's waiting for Magnus to make her move
as he car is happy
ah here so if Magnus doesn't do anything
active he car will will just repeat
moves with the king so here we have
bishop characters on e7 and magnus dux
sum over three minutes to decide on this
move you could go bishop therefore
there's no way to defend the c7 pawn but
it's it's questionable if the c7 phone
is actually worth anything it's a
doubled pawn but you could capture then
go maybe rook Bishop d8 and then
eliminate the night you know grabbing
the pawn in in doing so but Magnus
decides there's no need to it he just
captures the knight and after King
captures pushes a five he wants to push
f4 next and put all of his pawns on dark
squares so he carves light square Bishop
will be unable to challenge them so h4
by Hikaru starting to push his past pawn
also putting it on a dark square and now
f4 the king will now be able to reach
the pawn if needed and it will be very
hard to defend this age for now so he
Carl goes came to d7 now Hikaru has a
different plan he wants to bring the
King over to the Queen side both b5
sacrificed one of the points and then
also create a past a pawn so f3 by
Magnus and now comes b6 not b5 as if v5
then Carlsen probably just ignores it
so here b6 forcing magnets to make a
decision and now if you go for the a6
bone then the two the two outside past
bones are in fact extremely dangerous
so here Magnus decides to go for
character son b6 we have C captures and
b6 and only now Bishop captures an a6
which grabs a pawn but it kind of does
trap his Bishop hence the title fish
risk as Bobby Fischer in game 1 against
Spassky did trap his Bishop so here b5
and now across since Bishop is trapped
and he Carl will very very gladly just
win it by going all the way with the
king however it requires four moves so
what did Magnus figure out will happen
in those four moves he goes king f2 of
course he wants to eliminate this pawn
shift the King over to f6 attack the
Bishop forced up the ship to move and
then advance the e pawn that's the idea
so who's faster here he car goes king c7
with King to g2 we have King b8 King 2h
by Magnus kink the a7 going after the
bishop and now king characters an h4
kink a person a six he car is now up a
bishop but kink the g5 with King to b7
and now comes King to f6 now he carved
as Bishop has to move he can removes at
the d5 also puts pressure on the f3 pawn
but now Magnus doesn't push the pawn or
capture an a5 rather he takes a moment
to improve the position he plays c3 so
there's no rush now point is that he
wants to put this pawn on the dark
square not allowed black to push before
and then cement White's pawn and c2 and
this way you're you're also just
preventing before so kink the c7 he car
starts bringing the king into the game
and only now King captures on f5 so now
we have two connected passed pawns here
King D 7 and now came to f6 Hikaru grabs
one of the pawns with Bishop captures an
f3 but now e 6 with check with King te 8
and now kink the e5 making room for the
other point to start marching forward we
have Bishop to g4 by Hikaru
but now f5 we're Bishop to h3 he Carver
just has to wait and see what Magnus
will do we have f6 by Magnus Russia back
to g4 and now King to d6 going after
this pawn as well Bishop back to h3 not
much you can do here other than wait and
now e 7 now which is very strong putting
pawns on dark squares and at some point
if the bishop ever leaves that diagonal
you will be able to let's say play f7
get the King away and then just promote
the e pawn or you can just gobble up
these pawns so for example if the bishop
guards the pawn here then you just win
by f7 check you force the King away from
the bishop and next move you just Queen
the pawn
so instead Nakamura just Waits King to
f7 but now pink captures and c6 by
Magnus and it was also in this position
on 47 that he core Nakamura resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here so by nothing more to be done here
I mean after he Caro makes a move you
can never capture this pawn because this
pawn just Queens so you will have to
make some moves with the bishop but then
see seven you walk into a c6 is coming
once the bishop moves let's say bishop
before you're gonna go kink to b6 again
make room to advance the pawn so King f7
you're gonna go c7 Bishop f5 you gonna
guard the queening Square King b7 and
now doesn't really matter whatever you
play c8 queen is coming you're gonna
have to give up the bishop and next move
king here fall by queening and that's it
so really really impressive game Magnus
traps his own bishop but he calculates
precisely that it is in he has more time
to create two connected passed pawns and
to win the game regardless of being down
a full piece so that's game one of their
match I do hope you enjoyed it I'd like
to thank Richard nap Mike Wagner Hinkle
Lewin who signed out carrot and veil
Cove wahoo which for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the indoors
ably rapid challenge checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and if you
have a moment extra to spare do check
out the link in the description below
the first thing you will see it's it's
really awesome see you soon